our s about e these two letters stand
for high-performance cars but they can
top them too we're testing out the Audi
rs6 Avant performance it's got
thirty-three kilowatts more power than
the standard rs6 Avant car testa and
elite zimmelman says that the best thing
about the rs6 performance is definitely
the motor a four liter v8 with two
turbochargers that puts out 445
kilowatts and an amazing 750 Newton
meters of torque that makes the rs6
performance one of the fastest station
wagons in the world the car goes from
zero to 100 kilometers an hour and just
3.7 seconds that's 0.2 seconds faster
than the basic rs6 model some people
might not like the rs6 Avant
performances fuel consumption and co2
emissions but this vehicle is not
designed to protect the environment
Andre says that the motor grabs your
attention with its beautiful sound
especially in leave dynamic mode in
dynamic modal's even when standing still
this model rs6 projects Authority the
chassis is about six centimetres wider
than the standard a6
the tires are 275 millimeters wide on 20
inch rims extra length at the front and
especially the back are typical of this
series
[Music]
the powerful motor which is mounted in
front of the front axle is connected to
a classic Quattro Drive this layout
means that the car as a whole is front
weighted which affects its handling
would it han doori says that although
the rs6 is drive is weighted more to the
back which means more torque is
distributed there this car is better
suited to long straight stretches of
Autobahn and long curves than to tight
curves which it takes primarily with its
front wheels still you definitely feel
safe an rs6 rapidly approaching in your
rear-view mirror is an imposing sight
and there's a dynamic Plus option which
costs an additional fourteen thousand
euros and takes the cars top speed to
305 kilometers an hour
[Music]
the interior harkens back to the roots
of the Audi a6 but lots of carbon fiber
trim RS logos and the flat-bottom
steering wheel still give it a sporty
feel the start button is fiery red the
honeycomb leather seats are standard
[Music]
mid phenom Andre says that the rs6
performance is not a sensible car but
people who can afford it will find that
this car will perform well in almost any
situation and besides not being sensible
can be a lot of fun the rs6 is a station
wagon of extremes extremely fast
extremely powerful extremely exclusive
and extremely expensive
[Music]
you